yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we have a problem good to meet you
there is something I want to give you
it's already different than it is I'm
spent great so we're in character
creation I can select my background so
these are all the dungeon dragons
backgrounds that you know play Dungeons
& Dragons and I could play change my
body type
I can change my race so I can play as a
deep thing I can play as a drove it
plays a human basic it Yankee can play
as a dwarf there is an elf
there's a half elf I can play as a half
draw there's a halfling and there's more
but we're only showing a few these are
the races that will be going into early
access and they're more will be added
afterwards and so depending on which
race I think I get different features I
can also select which boss I'm gonna
play we have six classes that wouldn't
available an early access from the
get-go and then we'll just as before we
progress so I can place the wizard
cleric fighter Ranger rope and warlock
and then I can pick the abilities like
ability points that go with that and
select my skills in which I'm going to
be proficient today we're gonna play an
origin story so we have different origin
stories and there's gonna be five that
are gonna be an early access there will
be more often so this is my cell she's
the girl you saw in the intro so she is
a Yankee girl is a wizard he has a very
big problem and that's pretty much that
he's going to explode shadowheart she's
a dark cleric as she's 40 story - well
as a monster hunter who made a pact with
the devil he regrets it
and today we're gonna play as a star in
who is a vampire spawn he's a noble so
vampire spawn is not really a vampire he
has a vampire vampire to which he is a
slave he is a high elf which means that
we get to select a cancer for him so I'm
going to pick mage ham because we're
gonna do cool things with it and all the
rest is already preset for him so we
just have to click the venture forth
button and we can continue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're gonna skip the tutorial because
it's not ready yet
and so I'll tell you what happens in
tutorial or at least in a nutshell we're
gonna capture that No - Lloyd we're
going to do that together with to get
Yankee a warrior that you so captured in
the intro and we're gonna teleport it to
a place called faerûn and more
specifically to the sword coast more
specifically 200 miles to the east of
baldur's gate that was by the way the
city that you saw this charge is no ball
scale it was the art are
daylight is comfy
what the hell's going on so what I
forgot to mention is that my vampires
home and normally come walk in the
sunlight
he can't go over running water and he
needs an invitation if he wants to enter
somewhere but apparently he can walk
into sunlight so that's kind of handy
for us so he's going to try to figure
out what's going on so I can control the
camera and put it in third person so
then it's running behind me or I can
just go back top down and then basically
play it in a traditional manner so I'm
going to like going like this and that's
fine
over there
[Music]
sunlight
so this is a reverse voltage I alternate
let love push money and it reaches all
the way to baldur's gate but you have no
boat so we're go in a different
direction over here the love letters
none of my business
doesn't really care about like that
everybody's dead ask and introduce
ourselves
blasted doors like what huh it's you I
saw you on the ship you survived then
suddenly I saw what she saw felt what
she felt anger confusion results
you've got the same thing I do in your
head
I felt it okay so I have a whole bunch
of dialogue options so what just
happened to us is because of the tadpole
I was already introduced to that in
tutorial we call it mind-melding so we
both have a tadpole in our heads and we
can telepathically connect to each other
and then I'm also very hungry so I'm
playing this from point of view of a
star in vampire spawn so you will see
that all of my choices will be tailored
to being a star and essentially so I'm
gonna stare at her and realize that I'm
very hungry
has that tadpole scrambled your brain
already so I can basically say okay well
I will just feed or I can swallow my
urge and find ignorance which is what
I'm going to do because I needed a
companion come on the chase through hell
the creatures what they did to us the
tadpole that thing is going to consume
us from the inside and turn us into mind
flares you and I need a healer finding
one won't be easy in this wilderness
we'll need supplies I'm hoping something
of use might be behind these doors but I
barely made a dent in them so far okay
so I can offer to help her but I'm a
rogue also so I can tell her to save her
strength then that I will take the lock
by all means I'm going to see what's at
the top of this cliff
hopefully there's no more of these
creatures along the way I will well
actually I'll suggest that we joined
forces and say that that gives us better
also survival or just company for our
final moments but you're right whatever
lies ahead will be a little less
daunting with support you can call me
shadowheart
I can tell her that I'm a star in a
reformed vampire spawn we can walk in
the sunlight or can the choose not to
tell her which is a good ID and I can
also question her what she knows about
the things in each of our heads
very little supposedly those monsters
breed by planting their tadpoles in
people's heads over time the infected
victim turns into a mind flare I don't
remember how long it takes but we should
hurry so that's a problem I'll introduce
myself Starion lead the way sorry and
I've made my first companion that's
right so I'll pick that door but I don't
have a little big
oops and I got myself into the door
alright and let's see this fine
gentleman has something of use but he
doesn't
[Music]
that's usually an introduction to combat
when you see something like that let's
try and see where that is and this is so
combat is turn-based it goes tension and
drags a turn-based system so you place
yourself on that I need to be very
careful for these intellect divorce
because if they get too close to me it
will be very painful this can actually
end up in a party wives without do my
very best
I'm gonna stick the high ground and
dungeon dragons seeking advance which
allows you to roll twice which is a good
idea because a lot of dice are we going
on behind the scenes as you'll soon see
we translate the dice rolls into
percentages so that you don't have to do
all the mathematics yourself so this
gives me a 90% chance to hit so that's a
pretty good one also
I'll manage don't worry about it that's
a 45 percent up submit right I'm sorry
you need to damage so if you're curious
to know how the calculations are going
happening they're happening behind the
scenes here you can just hover over it
and then you can learn all of the math
behind the numbers that you see which is
why Jesse said lots of numbers we're
gonna be very brief and we're just gonna
go up there and then I'm gonna see how
far I can get this started because I
don't want him to die right away
alright shadowheart really me just my
recruiter the boom is action these are
my actions these are my bonus action so
you just see yeah it says a B it's a
little bit misleading it is actually
just the actions that you have but
sometimes you can have two of them so
I'm going to end my turn I know it's the
enemies turn unfortunate they can't
charm that's good
you can hit me that's actually enough
that that so what I'm gonna do with
shadow heart is I'm gonna try something
that's a little bit risky but sometimes
worse I'm going to use shop and I'm
going to try to
so that guys a little bit further for me
and then she can still hammer at that
guy really not hitting very well and
then I'm gonna shoot the deterrent that
guy yeah we're doing pretty good
actually
so common is fairly high stakes as you
can see so they have reactions that
basically means if she walks away from
here they're gonna hit her which is not
good so what I'm gonna do and he and he
comes so I have a job I didn't want to
use it yet but first I'm going to man
that's jump as a bonus action
so that means that I don't use another
film is action but it acts as a
disengage all so far and it's in the
house by myself all that I have inside
of me I do have one action that I can
still do so I'm just gonna try it up
this is my mage hands my match hand is
bad that's many things but it's very
good at throwing stuff so I'm gonna
[Applause]
I wanted to show this to you today but
you have no idea how nervous I was about
doing it because I was going to get in
this situation so I obviously should
have approached them and completely
different manner we'll see the next
combat how you can actually be much more
strategic running famous first I guess
alright she is hurting so she's gonna
bring my first giving potion I don't
have a lot of them then she's just gonna
actually
alright alright here comes that's good
oh no no no getting back up are you high
stakes he's hiding for the shot that's
interesting
okay um mage hands where are you do your
thing
to 80% so sorry yeah you can also throw
bodies that you find in the world but
it's not working so that's why I'm using
this shot actually yeah it's working but
it doesn't look Esther oh why did I go
to sleep i misclicked
really did I put my hand in to sneak
that's really clever okay so today the
announcement was that it was gonna be
life I think so alright 90% shot that
should oh yeah actually I have a pin
down in the back which is a action that
you get with your weapon so each point
that you get gives you an extra type of
action yes your I know that you're
sneaking you got this you got this
I have a plan I got a bottle with grease
so I'm just gonna choke can you stop
hands and I normally he's not supposed
to be able to hit like this actually can
you don't you do anything useful if they
want to attack you may be okay alright
so are they did kill hamsa hand is not
supposed to die
well swimmingly
okay so I wanted to throw so I have a
throw action I can throw pretty much
everything in a presentation I did
previously I threw my boots
so for comedic effect I'll just throw my
boots maybe I'll actually just go that's
not that actually
so where is she does one of those
anymore
that's so she's down she's not dead yet
so that's the good news
so basically how this works is this is
def saving true so each turn there's
gonna be a role behind the scenes and if
it's a good role and then we're gonna
get a little blue spot like this and if
you have three of them she gets
stabilized which is cool and if we get
three red ones because it's a bad role
then she dies and there are going to
keep on hitting at her because if she
goes to the negative over maximum HP she
dies too so we're gonna try to avoid
that from happening but I'm really not I
shouldn't have thrown to do this by the
way that was really stupid move
this looks like a really good kid good
thanks lens and we have one guy left
thank you why
okay well let's hope that this one goes
over right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well I did tell you that oh no
Stella
hold on this is work alright so so I do
have the savegame problem is real so it
is genuine so I need to restart so I'm
just going to do a quick restart I'll
just do this as fast and then we'll just
we'll do Q&A for five minutes
you got it out of the way early yeah
that's why they gave us in the half hour
extra yeah absolutely
you're fine I'll just